welcome back everybody 6 43 right now
i'm monica jackson thank you all for
joining me
as you start your work week i'll be here
every monday morning for mondays with
monica
and i'll be talking about everything
like parenting getting you through the
pandemic but this morning
oh i have a cautionary tale for you so
if you have a second especially ladies
in particular mothers
please stop what you're doing and pay
attention october is breast cancer
awareness month and as we come to an
end i want you to listen to a story of a
local doctor
she is a board certified doctor been in
practice for 20 years
has two adult daughters but it wasn't
until a freak accident
just at the end of last year where she
learned that her health
is just as important as that of her
patients her name is dr maria keller dr
keller how you doing
doing great this morning thank you for
having me monica
thank you for coming okay let's get
right into your story take me to that
moment last year
where you had a freak accident and then
excuse my friends all hell broke loose
absolutely so i was doing shopping you
know
uh went to a store bought a piece of
furniture
actually it's behind me and it had a a
long leg
uh and i went to reach it as the basket
was rolling towards me
and the leg of the of this ottoman stuck
me very hard in my in my right breast up
high
almost like a javelin it took my breath
away actually
what happened after that because you had
some bruising and then you took a closer
look
so about two days later i was looking in
the mirror and i saw
a lump in the upper part of my breast i
was examined it and i felt the lump i'd
never felt a lump there i do i'm an ob
gyn of course i know how to do breast
exams but i had
not felt a lump in that area in my
breast ever
and within three days i got a mammogram
showing that it was suspicious for
breast cancer and i can't imagine that
dr keller because i know you have two
adult daughters that would freak me out
and like a lot of women
i was late with my mammogram but i know
better you know better than most
it was cancer what did you do from there
because in that very moment i know your
life changes it flashes
so when i got the mammogram i'd asked
you know how long had it been
since my previous mammogram and i was
blown away four years
and how does that happen i'd maybe gone
at most two years but never that long
but
i got busy with life i started move my
practice from one location
to another uh i had uh issues that
happened in my business i did a home
remodel
and time just got away from me and so
uh i kicked into action initially i was
i kicked into denial because i didn't
want to believe the diagnosis i kept
thinking it was like a hematoma a bruise
a swelling
and so um about a month later i got
i was with my best friend she said
repeat your ultrasound she's a breast
cancer surgeon and i did
and she said if they recommend a biopsy
get the biopsy i did and the biopsy
showed
not only cancer and the mass but also
cancer in my lymph nodes
oh my god advanced cancer actually i'm
uh
diagnosed stage 3c which is one stage
the next stage before
you know metastatic stage 4. dr keller i
you know i've already admonished you for
this because i know you know better but
i also understand as a mother as a
professional
time does get away from you and now that
we're in the midst of covet everybody is
afraid
before we close out i want you to give
some advice to our
our viewers our mothers in particular
but women overall because
we cannot be so afraid that we miss
these appointments
my mother is a breast cancer survivor
and so my sisters and i always have to
get our mammograms but i was afraid i
was late coming to you
and when i saw you you were 30 pounds
lighter and it scared me
so please give a final uh piece of
advice to our viewers
well the thing that i would say is the
the 30 pounds lighter
a lot 20 pounds of it was from
exercising
10 pounds came from the stress once i
got my diagnosis
so um but what i would say to women is
that if you're late if you're delayed
please don't hesitate i didn't have
really any symptoms i would have thought
i would have felt
sick i was a little tired at the end of
the day a little
cold but nothing that would be a
significant symptom that i would have
expected that my body would have showed
me a little bit more
and so right now there was a point in
time when we had to shut everything down
for
uh screening for mammograms for women
because of covet
but now we know how to safely take care
of patients
we're doing the social distancing and i
don't want women to delay and hold off
on their mammograms it's so important
for us to get in there
and get the mammogram so we can get the
earlier diagnosis
that is the goal of mammography is to
pick up the breast cancer
sooner absolutely doc i'm out of time
but i want to let our viewers know first
of all thank you so much for sharing
such a personal story
but ladies if you would like to connect
with dr keller please give her a call
702-671-0006
or you can log on to her website live
agelessly.com you can also find this
information
on our website you can check it out
eight news now
dot com again doctor thank you so much
ladies i hope that helped you out
and sherry i know that uh you have been
out in the community
and you know over the years promoting
breast cancer
awareness so you know i thought it was
just a good thing to bring to our
viewers this morning
well nobody connects better than with a
personal story right
yeah when it's a doctor herself that's
in that situation
it really resonates so and you know moms
we put ourselves last yes we do we do
you got to move yourself to the top of
the list moms do it
all right thanks monica that was
terrific thank you